I'd like to talk to you now about the importance
of homographies and why we need to apply it
to the robotic vision worksheet. I've put
together some tips and tricks to improve your
homography. So let's go into MATLAB now and
take a look at these.
Okay so how does a homography actually work?
What does it describe?
Well if I look at the output of my tracked
mark script you can see I have these two figures.
Now on the left hand side I have my rectified
image with the calibration circles marked
with red asterisks. And on the right hand
side I have my regional robotic vision worksheet
image and the calibrations circles are marked
as well.
So what homography does is that I give it
the points of the circles on the right hand
side in this image and then I also compare
that to the calibration circle positions on
the left hand side and homography generates
a matrix which describes the relationship
between these two different viewpoints.
So once I have the relationship I can then
rectify the entire image from that H matrix
alone. So that is a very powerful tool and
allows us to do some cool things with computer
vision and robotics.
Okay so that's what a homography matrix is.
Alright so what are some tips and tricks when
you're writing your own getHomography function.
My first tip is that you need to make sure
that all the calibrations circles are in the
image. Alright so if you don't have all the
circles in there then it's going to very difficult
to generate a homography matrix.
The next tip is that the blob centroids that
you get from identifying the blue circles.
The centroid of that blob needs to be almost
on top of the centroid in the actual image.
Alright so if there's any misalignment between
the two centroids then the homography matrix
that you generate may not describe the relationship
between the different viewpoints that well.
The third tip is that because a homography
describes the plainer relationship between
two different viewpoints of your camera you
need to make sure that the worksheet is as
flat as possible. So make sure there are no
creases or folds in the worksheet. Because
once again if you do have any of those then
the homography matrix will not describe the
relationship that well between the two different
viewpoints.
And finally and probably the most important
point is that a homography works off the correspondences
between the points in two different views.
So you can see I've labeled my circles here
on the right and left hand side of the image.
And these numbers are correspond to the ordering
of the points that I supplied it when I generated
my homography.
So you need to make sure that the ordering
or the correspondence of the points is correct
such that you can generate the H matrix the
way you want to. And the way I did mine was
that I identified where the large blue circle
was, as you can see here's the circle number
two with the green asterisks. And because
I confined the large blue circle I could then
rectify my image on the left hand side here
such that the X and Y Cartesian coordinates
was located at the top left hand side of my
rectified image.
And the final thing to note is that you can
check the quality of your homography matrix
by looking at the residual so let's take a
look at that now.
Alright so let's look at my "getHomography"
function and check its residual on the output.
So you can see that the residual that's generated
is 1, 1.08 and that's really good, but what
does this residual mean?
Where does it come from?
Okay so if we have a look at the points that
I supplied to getHomography. I have P1 which
is the position of the circles in the X and
Y Cartesian coordinates. And P2 is the other
set of coordinates and that is the position
of the pixel centroids.
So what the residual is that it is the error
that's generated when you do the rectification
of the points so if I use the homtrans function
you can see where it comes about.
So while you homtrans on P2, you can see that
this is the point positions in the rectified
image and you can see when you compare the
output of homtrans to P1 that a matches quite
closely to other position that I want in the
alternate view.
But they're not quite exact. So there's a
residual when you do this comparison. And
this is where this maximum residual value
comes from. So when you do do your homography,
always check to the residual and to make sure
that it's not too large. A large residual
indicates that the homography matrix that
you generated poorly describes the relationship
between the two different viewpoints that
you supplied to the homography function.
So those are my tips and tricks on homographies.
Good luck with writing your own functions
and make sure you do the getCalibration function
and the getHomography function this week.